عواصف وامريكا ثلجيه تحرم اكثر من مليون
منزل امريكي وكندي من الكهرباء في ليله
عيد الميلاد وتلغي مئات الرحلات الجويه
مخلفه اضطرابات كبيره في حركه النقل
العواصف الثلجيه والاجواء المتجمده امتدت
لاكثر من ثلاث ثلاثه الاف ومئتين00 كيلو
متر بدءا من مقاطعه كباك في كندا وصولا
الى تكساس بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
العاصفه الثلجيه المميته شلت الحياه في
امريكا وكان كندا لليوم الرابع على
التوالي حيث ذكرت السلطات بان اجهزه
الطوارئ لم تعد قادره على التعامل مع
الظروف الصعبه الناجمه عن الصقيع وارتفعت
حصيله ضحايا العاصفه الشتويه الشديده في
جميع انحاء الولايات المتحده الى 28 قتيلا
مع استمرار البرد القارس والرياح وثلوج
خلال عيد الميلاد وفق وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه كما تسببت العاصفه الشتويه في
اكثر
من
2088 رحله جويه في انحاء الولايات المتحده
وتاخر
6600 رحله اخرى بحسب موقع التعقب فلايت
[موسيقى]
كما اتى الجليد والثلوج الى اغلاق بعض
الطرقات في البلاد وهي الاكثر انشغالا بما
في ذلك طريق انترسيت 70 العابر للولايات
والذي اغلق اجزاء اغلقت اجزاء منهم مؤقتا
في كولورادو وكانسيس وحذرت خدمه الارصاد
الجويه من احوال الطقس مميته وحدد سكان
المناطق المتاثره على التزام منازلهم
وافدت بان الرياح ادت الى انخفاض درجات
الحراره الى نحو 48 درجه مئويه تحت الصفر
في ولايه فلوريدا وتكساس انخفضت درجات
الحراره الى درجات التجمد وهي الدرجات
التي تقتل من يتهاون بها اذا ما بقي في ظل
لها وقت ممتاز وفقا ما ذكرت صحيفه اما في
كندا حملت مقاطعه انطاليا وكباك اللعب
الاكبر من الانفجار القطب الشمالي وشاهده
معظم وانحاء البلاد تحذيرات من البرد الق
والعواصف الشتويه
[موسيقى]